so to take one
mark that sounds
good my name is sonana Kelly I'm A Folly
artist and owner of f Folly
sound sound is a really crucial part of
any kind of
media to set in the
mood telling the
story you feel the emotion with
sound I'm always adding unique
props I don't know what it's used for
but I know it sounds
great Foley is everywhere in my life
always listening and always
learning
[Music]
Foley Art derives its name from Jack
Foley a Pioneer in the field of sound
effects during the early 20th century he
introduced the practice of incorporating
realistic everyday sounds into
films when they're shooting movies they
want the set to be really quiet quiet on
the set and action so all the sounds you
hear are recreated in a FY stage like
this one all right here we
go how long is she going to go
for Anytime the actor walks moves so if
they move their arm I have to do the
cloth movement for that footsteps
everything from beginning to end when
we're walking on outside the magical
thing that works
beautifully is this beautiful coffee I
personally prefer medium
roast it has like a little dirt sound
we're paying attention to what is going
on the emotion that the actor is feeling
at any given point if you notice when
people are said they drag their feet a
little bit so I put a little scuff to it
when and someone is sad and I'm going
like this with my hand is going to have
like a little drag to it if I'm happy
and I'm excited my hand is going to have
like a little upbe to it there's emotion
behind fully and that's why you can't
you know AI
it had to throw that one
in all our clients we love we love all
the projects but some of the ones that
stand out is like Ted lasso the cleaning
lady we also worked on Riverdale The
Walking Dead Shameless so we've done a
lot of
projects sometimes we say wiggle method
we use the actual prop that they
actually using if not you have to fake
them I'm going to show you how I'm going
to do the sound of frying
food I don't know if you guys ever had
these but they're pretty delicious it
tastes I'm if you're good you don't have
to taste them I'm just kidding but you
just poured them in here listen to
this
[Music]
I don't plan it too much ahead of time
like when I stay creative when I'm in my
poly stage I'm like ooh if I use this
with this that's going to sound so
great but like little
butterflies little creepy little animal
little
[Music]
bugs you know funeral always really
really sad it's really sad because we
usually have to go to the dirt pit and
dig their grave right
[Music]
here when I'm in here it just my brain
is always moving and turning trying to
again push the envelope try to make
something this much better how can I
make it better if I add Little Creek
little this little that to just make it
just
perfect with AI artificial intelligence
taking a lot of work in the movie
business home rting to everything
there's definitely going to be
challenges for people they have zero
budget and they don't care about sound
those people are cutting fully now so I
don't think is going to change much for
us anyone that cares about sound and
cares about their project they're going
to make sure there is a human touch to
it so the cell phone a lot of people say
well isn't that sound effects yes the
ringing is sound effects the beep beep
beep is is sound effects but anytime
they touch the
screen that's fully you have you know
the directors producers Movie Makers
spend millions of dollars to create
their Masterpiece and for them to choose
me and trust me with their project it's
just like such an honor and I try to do
my best to give them my best work and
just go the extra mile just to make it
that much perfect um I feel very lucky
I'm
blessed
[Music]